c'est ce que l'on voudrait éviter parce
qu'on voit bien que c'est la première
année où on ne désherbe pas et que ben
les herbes les mauvaises herbes à elles
et continuer à pousser depuis le mois de
juillet chacun doit désherber devant sa
porte forcément ça grince un peu des
dents c'est vrai que c'est pas évident
quoi quand on travaillait tous
désherbage du trottoir on a assez des
jardins et tours
c'est un peu exagéré on paie des impôts
locaux et puis bah parents nous ont plus
le droit d'utiliser de produits pour
désherber donc ça chaque proprio ou le
qatar de le faire enfin perso je les
fais pour ça fait plus propre le maire
de puiseaux explique pourtant qu'il
n'avait pas le choix et c'était beaucoup
plus facile avec les produits chimiques
de désherber et on ne désherber qu'une
fois par an plus que l'efficacité du
produit du rêve tout le reste de l'année
les employés municipaux utilisent
désormais leur auto fil pour désherber
les parties de voirie qui incombe à la
commune et cela il faut l'expliquer
l'interdiction d'utiliser ces produits
chimiques on faire désherbage manuel qui
lui nous impose de repasser beaucoup
plus souvent beaucoup plus régulièrement
et dans ce cas là soit de doubler le
nombre de personnes à la commune pour
faire le travail soit on demande aussi
aux baous vivre loin de nous aider comme
c'est prévu pour l'entretien des
trottoirs normal ça notre philosophie
des réfractaires à l'arrachage de
mauvaises herbes devant leur porte
risque dans l'absolu une amende de 250
euros